what's up guys my name is spencer
cornelia and so far this podcast has
made 95 726 dollars so make sure to
watch it five times so we can get over
that 100k mark
wow
wow that was incredible that was such a
great thing so just to intro who you are
spencer cornelia you are a house hacking
legend you also have an amazing youtube
channel that's been doing really well
lately and uh
old software developer back in the day i
have an interesting backstory but yeah
man house hacking's killing it right now
and youtube's blowing up so thanks for
having me definitely i've noticed on
youtube you've been uh well i think you
start where i found your channel was the
authentic or charlatan i did one on
youtube yeah i remember that video you
did on me so you would basically take
somebody online uh who maybe people
would would question
and really go through a deep dive and
analyze are they being authentic or are
they being like a fake guru and i think
lately it seems like this last like
eight months has really taken off for
the whole like the fake guru industry is
that a thing agreed i have had the sense
for a long time that a lot of what i've
seen was not really what it is yeah i'm
come from a very fortunate position in
life my family does pretty well and so
i've been around money in my life and
been very fortunate for that and so i've
seen what real wealth looks like
but i look at online and these guys are
flashy they've got the sports cars i'm
going to teach you how to get rich and
buy my course and teach you how to get
rich and so i've always felt like there
was something missing and that series
was simple there was no other reason
then let me just get an objective look
at people who are popular on social
media let me give them a fair shake and
let me see because i've i run a meetup
here in las vegas for real estate
investors and a lot of people were
coming and they were following the wrong
people or they were following fortune
builders which is a big business and
they one of these expensive seminars and
i just wanted to do something where i
say hey let me look into the background
of these people and figure out if if
they should be someone you follow or
somebody not and that was all it wasn't
so much about like ruining reputation or
anything and you obviously were a big
name and i felt like you were a good
voice in the real estate space so i did
a couple episodes that were probably a
little more negative and then i wanted
to do one where i kind of painted you in
a good light yeah the thing is though
negativity definitely gets the clicks
nobody wants to hear authentic or
charlatan oh he's authentic oh we knew
that they want to hear like he's a
charlatan
they do
and so it's uh well here's the thing i
don't just think it's your audience i
just think it's people in general would
rather hear something a little bit
negative it just gets
what are we not seeing exactly what
they're not telling you that used to be
that used to be a big thing see when i
first started making youtube it was all
about exposed if you put exposed in the
title this is like four years ago the
video would blow up yeah grant cardone
exposed dave ramsey exposed
all of them it gets great baby if you
aren't delivering and that's why i try
to do my best because i do know there's
some titles and i'm like oh that's a
sexy title and oh i know it'll get views
but
i think it's a little not fair for the
person i'm speaking about so there is a
fine line for sure on youtube yeah so
how do you pick people as a target or
like as a subject
not a target a subject
at this point a lot of people are i've
reached a point now where a lot of
people reach out and they say hey man
you really need to cover this guy so i'm
over here watching like sports
highlights and then yeah
thankfully for my audience thank you so
much for reaching out for those of you
who do send messages so that's generally
now is how i i see it but i'm also i'm
on youtube all the time this is truly
all i do i'm like a youtube addict yep
even in my free time i'm in the culture
you know i'm seeing what's going on what
what are people talking about what
videos are getting made and i'm doing it
for my own yeah you know you i'm sure
you do it where you see what thumbnails
are working what titles are working yeah
are there colors in the images what text
where's the text located so you made an
authentic or or charlatan video with
graham
as the main subject by the way it was
one of my favorite videos to make if you
remember it i told your story backwards
do you remember that i i listen i i know
i've seen that video multiple times yeah
because i felt like your story was more
interesting it's like oh graham started
youtube this this that and now he's
doing successful i think it's some
people it's more interesting to stay
here's where he's at today yeah let's
tell the story backwards there's a movie
called memento yeah that's amazing that
does that cool so what was the verdict
was he authentic or was he a charlatan
charlatan
if he was authentic what were the what
were like the core pieces of information
that you used to determine that he was
authentic was there anything working
against him that was charlatanesque i
actually have a question for you yeah
have you ever felt like a charlatan no
never good yeah uh so for graham
specifically does he do real estate boom
he's got verifiable success he shares it
um and then also with youtube that's
clear his day we can see the numbers you
also shared your numbers so we know the
income or we did before he stopped
making those videos oh gosh you know
what it got to a point where like it's
it sounds it sounds so arrogant to say
but the numbers have gotten too high to
make it like and then it's like you're
showing these numbers like these these
high numbers every like six months
i just can't do it i told jack the last
one i did was like how much i make with
three million subscribers and i was like
this is the last one i want to make even
then i didn't want to do that i was out
of ideas and i'm like well
this is uh this is my last one so i may
as well just go out with it a lot of my
videos the goal is awareness
now a lot of my videos aren't so much i
don't really attack the person i'm not
trying to like ruin people's careers it
was all about here's just
the here's the strategies they use so
for instance i have done recent videos
on instagram and how people can growth
hack on instagram it's not so much to
ruin people or
expose them it's more of here's what you
are seeing on instagram here's why these
people who we can't tell if they're real
or not they have a million followers out
of nowhere zero to a million in a year
so i i do a part of expose but also i
want to educate that way you're more
aware on the platform i think right now
social media is like the wild west i
think there's so much bad with it of
course we can also talk about the good
but there's also a lot of bad right now
yeah let's talk about the negative first
we want the negative what are some of
the red flags that you look for you know
what's funny is a lot of them are so
obvious right they are they come out i
did a guy recently who did uh who does
sports betting right and he talks about
i've won 24 of the last 25 days i track
him for nine days verifiably loser
i have i have my source has been
tracking him for another few days
verifiable loser comes on instagram
yelling in this phone 24 last 25 days
sign up for my package i guarantee i'll
help you make money but he was just
outright lying because you were taking
you were paying for his calls and he
said
this is oh your source was and then he
was just lying yeah so this is general
and then of course the stock market you
would never if you if i put money into
let's say you're a real estate uh you're
raising money yeah if i put money into
the graham stefan capital fund you would
never come out and say spencer i can
guarantee i'll make 30 return you would
never do that right because you're
ethical and you just understand that's
not
right we abide by a certain code of
ethics and morals and a lot of these
guys they need the money from social
media and this is where the trick comes
in where if you have real estate company
you've got a real business youtube you
can get by with not making much a lot of
these guys business is youtube so that's
why they promote so heavy because they
their courses are their only source of
income so if you come at them
you're potentially drying up the only
source of income but but let's say this
okay let's say that i found a way to
make a thousand dollars a month on
amazon and uh i i could replicate that
success with other people i could teach
that
but i'm making a million dollars a month
teaching people how to do that what is
your thoughts on that is is that wrong
to do because technically if you're
teaching other people how to do a small
amount it's just teaching is scalable
sure i focus a lot on the claims if you
came out and said i make a million
dollars a month and i'm going to show
you how to do it but you've never done
it to me that's where you get into that
line of charlatan but if you are very
transparent and say this is the method i
use i've been making here's my tracking
right i've got a paper right here for
all of my yeah my income from my house
hack i can show how much money i make
how much i spend and if you show that
and then it just so happens that enough
people buy where you're making more i
personally don't have a problem with
that okay as long as and let's be real
you're not taking advantage of others
too that's another aspect of this where
some of the core sellers i won't name
names but some of them are totally cool
taking someone's last
thousand they have a thousand fifty in
their account their course costs a
thousand they'll take that money all day
long yeah oh yeah i've seen some where
they tell you to open up a credit card
oh we could talk about the seminar
business if you want to get into
supervision
yeah one of my least favorite people
they he's in a part of a lawsuit so this
is public
the seminar business is one of the worst
in real estate and you appreciate this
because you're a real estate investor
and they get people in for the free
event they all it is is hype hi pipe i'm
going to teach you how to make so much
money in real estate with my proven
system six figures in three months and
then on the weekend seminar they barely
teach you anything you can go on bigger
pockets on a couple podcasts and learn
what they teach then they upsell you
into their mastermind well the reason
why you won't ever find the mastermind
price online you want to know why hey
graham call your credit card company
it's you know we'll see how much you can
afford say you're going to start making
200 000 next year because with our
proven strategy you're going to start
making 200 000 so call your credit card
company oh you got 28 000 approved well
it's 25 000 for the course me i got
fifty thousand a credit card limit it's
forty five thousand for me
so it's varies in price
how do you know this how many lawsuits
and it's it's shared if you really
research this you'll see it
so people are saying that they've paid
different varying amounts
for the same thing yeah based on their
credit cards yeah there's even a video
on youtube where someone goes undercover
and sees some of these shady practices
and lying to credit card companies it's
a shady business manager so i don't
understand the business so who
so so they go in and they call someone
else's credit card company i get you to
call yours oh and say because they'll
usually ask how much money are you
making we might be making 25 000 a year
but with my proven system you're gonna
start making 225 000 right so the credit
card company if you can claim that wow
they might give a higher limit oh yeah
so this is this is something that that
american express has recently started
cracking down on because they had an
issue with kovit that a lot of people
had overstated their income to get
higher credit limits and american
express saw that is more liability i
think same with chase
and so they lowered credit lines or uh
they requested your um tax return
there's a little thing there that says
that if you want this credit limit we
have we have the right to request a copy
of your tax return to verify you make
what you said you make tony man there's
so many dirty business practices in this
world on social media social media
driven is when i say social media a lot
of their audience comes from the
promotion of their brand on social media
that's interesting wow so who's going to
regulate that that's a great question
man coffeezilla and i are a good start
right yeah i've reached out to fdc
numerous times they've never contacted
me again i've never contacted me period
now i have a feeling the ftc is looking
at like the big fish here's even yeah
i make i'm probably gonna make 250 000
this year doing pretty well in life
right
some of these guys make 500 000 a
million were nothing yeah nothing
compared to some of the scams out there
in the world i did a video on online
dating scams and i started researching
it and some guy was like yeah this girl
has taken we found that she took 40
million or something you start thinking
of the scams out there we're talking 40
million 100 some of these bitcoins it's
like 600 million
well if you have limited resources what
are you going to go after you're going
to go after some guy who's like i can
teach you how to make a million i've
made a little money on e-comm i'm going
to teach you how to make a million
real scams now i i use the word scam i
try to use it as infrequently as
possible because someone calling your
grandma and scamming her that's a scam
someone
selling you a little more than what it's
worth that's yeah it's a gray line yeah
part of me believes it it's hard to
regulate because how much do you prove
is on the person with these claims
versus the work ethic of the person who
signs up because i guarantee you put
someone uh who's like so motivated like
a 19 year old kid who's like i'm just
gonna do whatever it takes i got a 15
000 credit line don't care i'm gonna
make it work and that kid does versus
someone else who's like trying to keep
you know jump from one thing to another
from another it's like oh i got 30k let
me spend that oh it's not working this
month i'm gonna leave how do they it's
like to go through all those claims it's
uh big part of my authentic charlatan
series was i wanted to i think it's very
important what guru you follow because
most information if you want to buy a
rental property a lot of it's pretty
similar go to but i do think there is
there are gonna be differences when you
follow so that was my goal is just bring
awareness is this guy real does he
actually do real estate or does he do
e-commerce or does he not
because that's going to matter on the
course side but then this ugly area of
how much responsibility do you put on
the student because i'm for sure i'm in
that ballpark where i do think
if you if you buy a course i can't
really go after someone if you buy the
course and you don't put in any work
right that's that's on you yeah
it's the unfortunate nature yes
and i think the reality to a lot of
people just in general whether they buy
a course or not are just very few people
really will follow through with it
whether or not they spend 100 bucks or
500 bucks or a thousand dollars and uh
i do think there is some level of
responsibility for the person buying it
to first of all verify what they're
buying is legitimate believe in what
they're doing and i think just knowing
how to be self-sufficient enough to kind
of fill in the gaps because i think uh
it can be good to get you in the door
get you thinking about some stuff but
then beyond a certain point if you get
if you get stuck it's like oh i got
stuck let me quit here's my only clap
back to that right so if i if i'm
selling a course on how to how to get
started on youtube and i sell it's going
to be incredibly difficult you're
probably going to need to have this much
money to start for camera work all that
stuff uh and this is the timeline right
it's going to take you possibly up to
three years to get your first 1 000
subscribers i have nothing no problem
with selling that
the problem becomes when you are selling
i'm going to teach you how to be a
millionaire i saw one guru teaching i'm
going to 100x your subscribers in 12
months
you can't promise that right yeah i mean
you know youtube come on there's there's
some there's some difficulties with
growing that fast i mean it's not
everyone can do it first i want to thank
our sponsor upstart if any of you guys
have ever experienced credit card debt
or high interest debt it can feel like
it's never ending jack i know exactly
what that feels like i had some credit
card debt myself but the first step to
being financially free is paying that
credit card debt off i know i've done it
myself and i think if i've done it i
think you guys can too and that's
exactly why we want to tell you guys
about our sponsors today upstart upstart
is a way that you can consolidate all of
your high interest debts into one low
monthly payment and the best part is
it's all online and upstart knows you're
more than just a credit score they
actually consider your employment and
your income to find you a smarter rate
on your loan and if you have just five
minutes you can check your rate up front
if it's a loan between one thousand and
fifty thousand dollars and you get your
funds as quick as the next business day
now that's
speedy
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments when you go to
upstart.com ich that's upstart.com
ich don't forget to use our url to let
them know that we sent you loan amounts
will be determined from your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com ich thank you so much
upstart for sponsoring this episode and
back to the podcast
so
the problem lies in the marketing right
sure if you're funneling people who
shouldn't be buying so where i come in a
lot of my content revolves around the
lack of disqualifiers right you should
not buy this if you if you don't want to
work on weekends you shouldn't buy if
you only have a thousand dollars in your
bank account please do not buy that's
where i think the ethics start to come
in ethics is a little subjective right
that's where sure
i'm cure i want to put you on the spot
what do you think of my youtube creator
academy program be honest i haven't gone
through it okay i have not gone through
the course okay but
with that said i've heard good things
i do know that our friend ryan our
friend went through it and he's made
seven figures on on youtube
also don't promote so link down below in
the description if you said anything bad
i'll be like all right all right like
down below but the thing is you don't
you don't really promote it hard right i
would have a problem okay let's say so
here's a good example you have the same
information course a and course b exact
same information but in the funnel in
course a you're promoting as guaranteed
way to make a million you know
i've shown videos on how much money i
make i can guarantee you'll get there
for course a but course b you just say
here's the course if you want to get
started on youtube
you can buy it if you want can you see
that there's pretty clear difference
yeah right even though it's the same
material
you have to do that though uh
i think that's just that's just what's
required because think of it this way
when when i first started making youtube
videos
when i looked on youtube for financial
advice or just financial videos you'd go
on there and it would be like
a title how to start a roth ira or why
you need a roth ira like those would be
the titles
i switched my title to
uh how to be a tax-free millionaire by
60.
you have to do that because otherwise
the people who need to see that
wouldn't see it because they don't know
what a roth ira is they want to know tax
free millionaire how do i roth ira so i
think
some of that is just is required you you
have to
sprinkle a little bit of sugar on it
because it attracts the people who
otherwise would have overlooked it
because they don't know what to look for
yeah marketing sugar guarantees are you
guaranteeing anything that's usually the
best start yeah there's nothing wrong
with marketing a product look i
understand business
excuse me but
there is a line though i think we can
agree and i yeah yeah yeah
i think we agree on i'm just uh i'm just
given some counterpoints that's all yeah
but i think overall we agree on the same
things yeah i'm not anti-course by the
way which is generally i think a lot of
my fans think i'm anti-course i'm not i
think there are a lot of courses out
there that could really help people
honestly i've struggled on youtube for
five years had i gone through your
course earlier and condensed you know
what's the value of cutting some a
success from zero to five years from
zero to three years yeah right you know
what you should you should go through it
if you want to if you want to go through
it i actually should add yeah i was
thinking of doing a mentorship for
youtube and someone reached out with
notes on your program so that's why i i
have seen notes and it i i saw it and i
was like this is this is solid okay i
was about to say if you uh if you go
through it you don't like it well well
it doesn't matter i don't want to make
this
will refund you in 21 days if you don't
like it down below in the description
what would be really interesting though
a question to ask to put you on the spot
is do you feel like you would ever
withhold information for a course
uh
there are a few things that i think yes
uh i don't think i don't think there's
anything big like i'll tell you i think
our thumbnail strategies change so often
right so i would say
that information
what's in the course right now
works tried and true but gosh i have to
say with thumbnails lately with jack and
i it changes every like three to four
weeks here's my so for me yeah yeah
against course creators is that i
personally believe that success comes
from mentorship and constant i do know
you i do you still have the monthly
mentorship i do i've heard good things
and i think that is a better strategy
especially with youtube growth on
youtube how valuable would it be if i
sat here and showed you a couple
thumbnails and you said a b and c change
those thumbnails just do this one little
thing like that's insanely valuable
right but you can't put that in a course
uh you get that in the mentorship you
can the mentorship is down below
but uh i think overall um
for for as far as like with withholding
information there's other things like uh
i'm not gonna mention what it is but you
mentioned something to me really
interesting and i wouldn't put that in a
course yeah uh but it's also not tested
right so these there's a lot of things
out there that i believe could work but
i but i don't believe it enough to be
able to talk about it and put it like in
a program for everyone to see when it's
like may or may not work i haven't tried
it long enough thumbnails change so
frequently do you believe youtube is an
art or science
uh it's got to be
both i feel like it it has to be both it
has to be 50 50. because and it's it
sucks because like you could have the
perfect video but if you don't know what
to title and thumbnail it nobody watches
it so it's like i really believe title
first then thumbnail is equally as
important and then the content second
so agreed yeah i think it's never ending
and go back to the course part that's
why it's it's always evolving so you
can't really put like what i'm doing now
on youtube is different than i did six
months ago which is different than 12
months ago how do you put that in a
course do you constantly update it and
possibly i think it's different from
yours so my thumbnail is what works for
me i might have a the same click-through
rate than you do yeah totally different
look yeah and i well here's here's what
i think i think the strategies to get
from zero to let's say ten thousand zero
to really there's not a lot of
difference between ten and fifty
thousand in terms of strategy i think to
get from zero to ten let's just call it
zero to fifty
it's pretty much this is going to be the
same for
eighty-five percent of people so
my my program at least really describes
from starting from nothing to get to
that point we're at least starting to
make some momentum you're good but i
would say once you get above
50 to 100 000 subscribers that's where
there's like you you got to start
testing what works for your audience
that's what's hard to put in a program
you just you there's no
one-size-fits-all right there's some
thumbnails i look at i'm like oh that's
awful 1.8 million views channel 400 000
subs and you're like yeah how yeah but i
gotta say from zero to ten thousand i
think it's just the like that the main
few points is just like you gotta upload
consistently good content good title
thumbnail you gotta rank for seo and you
just gotta get enough from youtube
search to get some data on on your
channel that it could then recommend it
so i think just in terms of growing like
that
that works pretty universally have you
ever had any issues with them like
reaching out to you you made a video on
them and they're like hey take that down
or like they want to rebuke those claims
where do you want to start and you want
to start with a lawsuit or the other day
when a fake guru called me out of
nowhere let's start with the lawsuit
first okay
i'm getting sued right now um by a guru
he i made a video on him i had a guest
on to speak about this guru of
first-hand experience a former co-worker
with this
guru i'm getting sued and my lawyer's
twenty thousand dollar retainer fee
there's already been work being done uh
we're gonna file a motion to dismiss for
anti-slap it's absolutely a frivolous
lawsuit but it is the unfortunate part
of
this business coffeezilla called me the
other day he was want to chat about it
he has insurance lawsuit insurance yeah
to cover him which i didn't i don't make
videos that i was worried about lawsuits
ironically enough it was the one where i
had a guest on and we spoke about
someone
so that's unfortunate unfortunate side
of what i do so yeah media insurance is
extremely expensive jack so if you guys
want to pay for this yourselves i pay
over a thousand dollars a month just so
that something happens that i am
partially covered it's a big deal and
the thing is you don't even need to say
anything wrong you could say all the
right things and someone go oh i don't
like that you said that bad that's no
that's naughty jack's laughing because
he hasn't seen the he has not seen no
just the the threats and and and just
the issues that you have when you when
you open yourself up to a possibility of
a lawsuit you've received gosh that's
what you're saying what's up you've
you're receiving these no no threats oh
yeah yeah threats you've received
threats thankfully nothing has ever
happened interesting but yeah thankfully
nothing you're pretty political oh yeah
that's why yeah i'm gonna guys i'm gonna
convince them we gotta get you on the
side you know when you see something
shady you're gonna call it
listen i
i'm not gonna i i stick with with just
myself but uh but i do speak
less about people but with companies
so so it's not like i'm calling out like
oh joe's over there but i've said
negative things about certain companies
and i've had those companies reach out
to deeper pockets right and so
like i'm not going to risk it i don't
think it's a
it's very serious and i've seen also
what it's done to to kevin i've seen
what what kevin would do yeah kevin
hasn't stopped that's the point it's
worth it for him for full transparency
and all of that he did stop
he still pushes it a little bit
obviously the one thing that the the
things that he did to get sued were very
extreme agreed he toned it back a little
bit but i don't think that we would get
to that extent obviously it would be a
higher risk if we were to be ful like
talk about the certain things and and
say people's names and stuff like that
it would be higher risk but at the same
point i think just for transparency sake
and for the quality of the like that's
the stuff that if i was a viewer i know
for a fact i would want to know that
stuff it just sounds exciting no
my philosophy is you stick with with
yourself in my opinion if it's public
record i think we should be okay exactly
yeah no i'm not i'm not going to take a
risk you have a lot more to lose than
you do and plus it's not really your
brand whereas it's my like there's going
to be a rally when i win this
this guy's there's going to be videos
about this i know a lot more than he
wants me to know right leave it at that
right there's a lot of shady stuff and
so um i have reached out to him and told
him i'd sign an nda messaged him on a dm
on instagram and just said hey before we
get lawyers involved i'll sign an nda i
understand why you're mad no no hurt
feelings i totally understand guess what
happened
it was an automated message you want to
sign up for my real estate my business
mastery my stock market mastery and i
was like really so my next message was
please send this to the guru
and uh it's regarding our lawsuit
blocked wow all right you want to play
that i was gonna be nice
yeah and now you're gonna now we'll have
fun with it my lawyer's really strong
i've got enough money to pay how much is
that gonna cost i don't know if you
wanna know that yeah oh yeah i can talk
about it twenty thousand for a retainer
i'm already about probably six grand
maybe ten grand into it
on top of the retainer now the retainer
will come back to me when the case is
closed but this could get 40 50 grand
which for me that's that's a huge hit
that's money i'd much rather invest
here's the thing you're dealing with
somebody else so who is litigious
who can continue to drag this out and
bleed you drive money i've seen this
happen to other people you are you are
taking the risk right now
that it might not be 20 grand it could
be 50 with the potential to drag on for
two years
and you're like 20k 20k 20k 20. and the
deeper you dig on this
the more you're invested the harder it's
going to be to pull out and that money
doesn't come back and then
i don't know man i i've seen too many
cases of people not collecting on this
or throwing good money after bad the
good thing is i do have a platform
that's my leverage i can talk about it
hey man there's been uh h3h3 had a yeah
that was huge for him
they basically ended that guy's career i
think yeah backstage and he also that
was
a net benefit for h3h3 right overall
because also you got the fair use thing
right so the whole fair use precedent
you know combined with the content that
you know ethan h33 got out of this this
whole thing i mean it's net benefit huge
so that's what i'm hoping for yeah there
there's gonna be a cost i'm also not as
tied to money like i used to be i'm okay
man as long as i roof on my head i got
opportunity pretty filipinos out there
then i've got plenty of opportunity to
live a good life yeah man
that came out of left field i'm like
okay sometimes food water
really filipina alright
hey we're gonna tell jokes on the
podcast yeah the light light in the mood
a little yeah there you go we're talking
about lawsuits come on throw some humor
in there okay who's the other one who
called you and yes i made a video about
a sports betting guru he made claims of
buying a four million dollar house in
las vegas which he probably didn't know
i was a realtor made it a little easier
to search for this information and he
made a lot of claims about how much
money he made made a video about him one
day ring ring about 8 pm hello hey
what's up man hey who is this hey what's
up it's the person i made a video about
oh hey how did you get my number how's
it going talked about the video he was
very respectful nothing nothing ugly or
anything and after about 10 minutes he
was a little upset about the video he's
like i'm going to dinner i'll hit you
back
nothing happens 30 minutes later text me
my address
i was like oh
yeah that's where i live
send it to lawyers just to alert them
and then about two weeks later i'm
sitting at the gym i get another call
from a 702 number i answer it it's
someone talking about the video hey what
can we do to get the video taken down
well this sounds like a bribe to me is
that what this is this a threat no no
man this isn't a threat okay what's your
relation to the person who made the
video oh i'm just a guy behind the
scenes i just do little things here and
there i was like this sounds like a
threat to me yeah i will alert the
lawyers if if you do anything silly so
please watch your words carefully and he
just goes no man no no we're cool just
you know your business man right how
much is it going to take to you know
what's it going to take to get the video
taken down it's like i can't be bought
he's and then he kept going he once he
realized i couldn't be bought i think it
threw him off because he's got no
leverage i've i caught this guy he's
he's a fake guru and uh he's got no
leverage anyway so after at about the 11
minute mark i say look man i was waiting
for him to say something really stupid
yeah yeah because then i can go okay now
i got something but we're going to
record the phone call i couldn't no i
don't know how but also in las vegas
you'd have to have two-party consent
yeah but anyway i say hey i've got one
minute left
phone gets handed over to the fake guru
hey what's up man it's so and so i was
like oh you were listening the whole
time and he starts yelling at me i don't
know why you're doing what you're doing
is weird man it's not cool blah blah you
didn't even buy my picks and all this
and then he hung up that's that i hope
he doesn't keep that was the last how
long ago was that that was uh two weeks
ago that was two weeks two weeks ago and
this this is a sports bettor who
lives here in las vegas i know where he
lives
you should just text him his agent why i
already know where he lives yeah he
knows i talked to him about it i was
like look man why'd you why'd you lie
why did you say you bought a four
million dollar house when you didn't
what how much was his house
i'm not going to say because that will
release public information but uh he did
not buy it is the catch he didn't even
buy it thankfully i i'm at the point now
i had a mortgage uh loan originator in
town reach out to me he's like he helped
me kind of behind the scenes
see it's so awesome because you're in a
position where like
you own two properties and you rent out
the properties and you make good money
house hacking these you're profiting a
lot
and it seems like like you're pretty
stable financially so you're at a place
where you'll be able to take these these
sort of risks to to do what you want and
make the exact type of content that you
want because you're comfortable enough
to be able to
to do all of that yeah exactly i'm at
this is the turning point today is the
turning point this is a big moment for
me because over the past couple years
i've had a lot of struggles financially
there's also graham you were someone
that i followed for years like there
were i spent five years trying to grow
on youtube i really wanted to i just
wasn't good at it yeah if you look at my
old video they're not good and i
couldn't grow but i always looked at you
and i was like okay if graham can do it
if the upside is what he's making this
is worth it there's a concept by nassim
taleb called
asymmetric outcomes and what you look at
is if you look at five year of youtube
let's just use numbers say it's a minus
100 loss every year from energy time and
a little bit of money minus 100. well if
the upside is an income of 50 000 a
month or a year or whatever it's worth
it and so that's what i always viewed if
you're the upside
every amount if it takes me eight years
i'm going to do it if it takes me 10
years i'm going to do it because if
that's the upside it's worth it the
outcome is worth the amount whatever the
amount of time is and so today getting
on this podcast was indicative of an end
to the previous phase where i lost all
my money flipping houses i had the
current household in it
120 000 renovations i mean it was wild i
had so listen to this real quick i lost
all my money flipping houses in
cincinnati two properties lost about
ninety thousand between the two i got to
a point i had to sell my car i was
riding the bus four hours to and from
work every day like making as i was
growing on youtube i was riding the bus
two hours every night just to get home
and and then so i get out and then i
start to rehab my current house hack i
want to make it a little nicer before i
officially bought it well we get into
the rehab and there's a sewage problem
underneath the house
do you know what that means
bring in the jackhammer baby so some of
these videos that have done really well
i was doing i had to wait until the
jackhammer
completed and i've got videos i'll show
you after this there was a jack camera
in my house for two weeks and i had to
wait until the no i have people living
in my house working in my house working
from home with a jackhammer so it was a
31 000 expense i had concrete around it
ended up being about 110 000 rehab wow
and so i went through with that
and that i was spending money i didn't
have like i was putting all in credit
cards and then as youtube money came in
i paid it off and now right when i got
to
the point of being even meaning all my
debts paid from previous renovations i
get sued so it's like
there's been so many setbacks man but
like i'm so optimistic like i'm probably
one of the most optimistic people you
meet all i do is look forward there's no
looking back looking forward you worried
about flying a little too close to the
sun no not at all really i'm
i'm arrogant in this way i will always
find an answer always i always have and
i always will
is it worth it yeah of course it is i'm
in the time quite well yeah i'm in the
high growth stage now like i'm i'm i
don't need much in life i just bought a
tesla i have a roof over my head
i'm super simple with food like i'm not
a foodie i don't need jewelry there's
nothing i need yeah what i want is
opportunity and i have that right now
right now i'm experiencing hyper growth
i'm sure you remember that stage with
the podcast you guys are killing it like
that growth is there's no high that can
match that there's no drug that can
match that high when you start growing
well at least for us on youtube
and so i yeah i'm in a great great spot
right now where i have the opportunity
to reach the goals that i set out for
myself and to me that's all that i want
is it worth potentially risking that
let's say there's a five percent chance
one in 20 chance that uh you talk about
the wrong person you get a big lawsuit
and they just
drill it in sure and you lose and you
lose all of that growth
you get the stress on top of that uh
everything you've worked for in that
that hyper growth phase is is risked can
happen man it can happen any time
anything can happen in life after you
there's a quote in fight club it's only
after you've lost everything that you're
free to do anything and i was down to
dude i couldn't buy i had ripped shoes
that i was walking on when it rained
that sucked i was riding the bus four
hours too i'm researching videos on
youtube and i got like a crack head
behind me yeah dude there's there's not
much lower than that i could barely
afford food so i was like strategically
spending money i would pay my minimum on
the credit card and then that would
allow me to buy food right because you
pay the minimum now you have like 100
remaining well that's my food budget for
the next however much so like once you
go through that man you can you're free
to do anything i'm i'm happy i'm good
i've got a car dude go go two years
without a car in las vegas you'll
appreciate the cars yeah you told me
you're riding the bus everywhere in fact
everyone's almost going to ride a bus
here yeah but intentionally the tesla
came in time i was almost going after i
was like looking at the looking at the
route hey jack can you pick me up yeah
wow what did you get what tesla did you
get model 3 2021 so i was going to use
it for turo
wow so you're you're hacking everything
basically so you want to do the tesla on
tour how much you expect to make from
that i'm thinking gross maybe two 2 500
a month minus a thousand for payment and
insurance so let's call it maybe a thou
there's gonna be some problems here and
look i i might do it for a month and
realize youtube is where the energy
needs to be at i'm making 22 23 000 a
month on youtube youtube
yeah that's the money maker this is more
like content and i'm a man of my word i
said with lucky the video we did two
months ago i said i was going to do it
and so i got to do it now i said it on
video
you may as well try it for a month worst
case you can make a video actually
there's an interesting conversation so
you brought up the risk so here's what i
do i'm actually
an interesting investor so i go for
super high risk like i love super high
risk investments i think it makes life
fun but on the underside of that i have
stability what's my stability house
hacking this is why i'm so big in a
house hacking so i just bought my second
house it's in the beautiful southwest
part of las vegas beautiful zip code
super awesome house half a million
dollars and i'm now at 8 600 a month
gross from two houses and i want to buy
two a year
so it's not going to 600 a month gross
between two houses two houses that's
incredible yeah so i do what's called
house hacking you're familiar you buy a
house rent by the rim so i go the
extreme so i have one house at seven bed
five baths and then a second house that
i'm converting into a six four it's a
five four currently so i'll have 12
tenants see you between the two and you
live in
which yeah i'll just keep i'll i'll keep
house hacking so i'll i'll move into my
marry yeah buy it as a primary owner
occupied right now
yep each year i can buy one right
because i'm putting five percent down
and then as youtube grows i'll be able
to buy an investment property 20 down in
tandem with the owner occupied what
about the leverage
i don't worry
you want to know what it would take for
me to for that business to crumble vegas
would have to shut down right well not
for that that's totally separate these
are llc's separated like meade would
have to drive yeah
i'm almost like again
i don't know the biggest defense against
lawsuits is being guilty i'm not guilty
i'm totally innocent about charges i
don't unfortunately i don't think see i
i don't know i don't want to get too
much into the lawsuit sure but i
disagree i disagree you also lawsuits
are not guilty i i think a lot of
lawsuits are whoever has more money true
but here's the thing man life is life i
i don't know how long i'm gonna be here
i just live i do the best i can today
and you live on live with the results
right yeah i know i just i don't want to
see anything happen that's off that's
all i'm saying is it's like you've
worked so hard you got these properties
everything's going so well
i'm just saying maybe but he is
diversified across like house hacking
he's got his youtube channel
even even with an llc it's it's easy for
not easy but a lawyer could always claim
that you know you could pierce the
corporate veil as they call it and those
llc's or
did you almost know your youtube channel
what's up you almost lost your youtube
channel didn't you uh oh
my god
yeah i mean that was that was i was i
was
99.999
that nothing was going to happen and it
just my point after i lost all the money
i yeah these big plans i'm going to be a
big youtuber i'm going to make so much
money in real estate and all this and
then when life throws you a curveball
you realize man there's a lot outside of
your control this is actually a question
for you guys yeah how much do you think
luck and timing plays into your
financial success
um so i'm mixed on that because on the
one hand you could look objectively and
be like well he started investing in
2010
you know and yeah in l.a and everything
and everything has gone up in price
since then uh i've only really ever
invested through a bull market i
remember the market collapsing in 2008-9
didn't really have anything to lose i
was just starting my career
uh so in in that sense absolutely that
was that was
luck but the but the other thing that i
look at is that like you know how much
of that was luck versus how much of that
was seeing an opportunity and
recognizing that
so there's risk involved you're putting
money into something in hopes that
yeah and here's the thing too it's i
remember in 2010 when i was interested
in buying real estate how many people
said it's gonna get worse now is a
really bad time the market just
collapsed it's not getting any better
there's so many foreclosures coming in
the market there's shadow inventory that
was coming up that it it's going to
crash it even further it's still going
down you should wait for it to recover
uh
and and i remember when i was submitting
offers i mean like every house was it
was a short sale there's not it was rare
to see a normal house on the market
versus rare
and uh for me it was like it just i saw
the opportunity it made sense i was like
even if it does go down i'm buying this
house for a fraction of what it costs to
build it like this this is a 200 000
house to build and it's selling for 70k
there's no way that's sustainable so for
me it made sense to buy and uh timing is
an interesting element though so if you
look at life like some people they get
married have their kids they're
financially ready to buy
fall of 2007. right it's just the way
their life works out they were born in a
certain year their their job led to a
certain income and down payment at a
certain time they don't know any better
so they buy at that time versus someone
who who's timing that same person that
timing they were ready to buy until okay
we're going to buy a house this is on
the market we'll buy this one because we
like this yeah right that's the crazy
i'm not i'm not criticizing you or
anything yeah i know i know luck and
timing is very interesting i've gotten
bailed out by a good market too i got
fortunate that i was able to sell my
houses that i lost a lot of money on
yeah i mean youtube how about youtube
like i'm super lucky in that i kind of
joined this coffeezilla he was a little
ahead of me we joined this kind of
movement that didn't really exist and
it's blown up yeah but here's the thing
i think in a sense you do create your
own luck because i remember when i
started youtube 2000 late 2016 december
i was too late
i cannot tell you how many how many
thoughts that i had it's like it's all
everything has already been done i am
too late to this uh youtube is a huge
uh but i did it anyway and now looking
back he's like oh yeah well in hindsight
yeah that was the perfect time to do it
so i don't know i believe there is uh
there is a sense of what's outside of
your control that is just pure luck but
i also believe there's a sense that you
create your own opportunities you create
your own luck had i not posted on
youtube because uh you know it was too
late p i i bet people are looking at the
same things now and believing it's too
late to do this or it's too late to do
that where five years from now i'll be
like oh i was so lucky i started right
now so i believe yes there is there's
some of it that's outside of your
control but i believe there's no there's
no
uh benefit to looking at luck because
that's outside of your control so i just
think it's like what's the point of
focusing on luck or no you don't control
that focus on what you can control the
timing of it i agree it is kind of a
moot point to think just about luck and
and where you place on that and
but also i do agree that there there is
a spectrum between between luck and
timing and and you know your actions and
stuff like that because
look to throw out an example okay i'm
very very very fortunate to be in the
position that i'm in right but finally
as i'm 22 and as i have enough money to
afford a home we have seen the craziest
run-up outside of you know a pandemic
and and the supply chain issues and
stuff like that like one of the craziest
run-ups in real estate and now i'm
looking at homes in the first home that
i'm going to buy it's like it's
it's probably going to be like in the
500 000 you know right around that range
but i asked graeme yesterday i was like
how much was the first home you bought
and he's all 56 and i was like 59 000.
oh 59 i'm like 59 he's like 59 thousand
dollars and i'm thinking to myself like
that's the down payment like to be able
to afford a home you know that's fifty
nine thousand dollars versus five
hundred and ninety thousand you know
what in fairness i think we are putting
down about the same amount of money i
paid for that home home in cash
i was all in 72. i would have to putting
down twenty percent so 500 oh so you're
putting down a little bit twice a little
more yeah okay yeah okay but also like
but he's buying in vegas which is a way
better market than california
[Music]
that's true so but but then again it's
like i look at that and then i also
think like look how lucky was i that
graham got back to my first email and
then i got to start working with him you
know what i mean like was that luck or
was that my action me going out of the
way to email someone that i admire and
yeah and that's the thing too a lot of
people could look at jack oh jack just
luggy
working with graham but yeah jack sent
me like eight emails one of these days
jack we're going to go through those
emails no we can't
oh my god for a podcast no no no no no
no no no they're embarrassing please
i honestly think if we do it we should
actually do it on like the second
channel where it's where it's actually
gonna get like we may as well make it
worth our walk by the way i prefer using
the word fortunate i think is a better
word because luck does have some
negative connotation where it's like you
only made your success
but that's just good for you i like the
word luck people it's a nuanced
conversation that i find interesting
so the intensity of success you've had
yeah you have to attribute some to just
good fortune and and and just well if
you did if you did grow up and you
finally had money you know you're you're
20 years old you've been working for a
couple years you made your own luck with
the real estate agent i mean you did
that you yeah executed beautifully right
which is a grind exactly but at the same
time when you finally have money and the
you know the market's basically at its
bottom and you're buying real estate and
then you become a millionaire through
equity and appreciation due to timing
and then you make a video how about your
real estate millionaire it's like it is
a it is a combination of both luck and
action because you also decided to make
youtube and you decided to get started
in real estate yeah here's what i'll say
um here's where i do feel like i've i've
gotten lucky uh and i'll be i'll be
honest with this i think that
being born into the family i was born
into in la getting to see other people
who had absurd amount of wealth in los
angeles
not having that and looking like wow all
of these people have this
what what is it what is it about these
people where they could live in beverly
hills in a 10 million and just seeing it
and wondering and that gets my mind
going like why do some people have this
ferrari i remember like you know seeing
these cars like so people are doing
bitcoin they're doing
uh but then having two parents who were
uh very supportive who are not abusive
and um
you know
and uh
are they still together no
no no it's pretty well my parents are
still together it's like weird that i
see that as a huge advantage in life
like one of the best now
i don't think so to me
household yeah yeah otherwise yeah they
divorced when i was five and i don't
remember much before that but i just
remembered five my dad got an apartment
um and
i like it listen being five i didn't
understand what was going on but i liked
it because i had like mom's house where
mom was kind of strict and wouldn't let
me watch south park
and then she was daddy's house out of
the jar and then dad's house was like i
could eat food on the couch while
watching like adults swim and like
naughty cartoons
so yeah
not like this but like south park um
gosh what was the other one there was a
tv fun house on comedy center like the
comedy central shows yeah uh corolla and
yeah jimmy kimmel the man show
i loved so i'd watch those i go to my
mom's or like jerry springer i could
watch that at my dad's house but i go to
my mom's like no no no no nick jr
um so but but now honestly having mom
doesn't have her dad doesn't have the
parental controls oh oh you know what my
mom hated this too and here's the other
reason why i kind of liked going back
and forth was because my dad would allow
me to play uh nintendo 64 golden eye and
my mom was very against any sort of
violent video games so i couldn't play
that there but i could go to my dad's
house and play conker's bad fur day um
but no but but having two parents that
were really supportive that never
ridiculed me that if i had an idea they
would always entertain it they were so
encouraging of me like i remember i
wanted to uh get a reef aquarium and uh
i think it was either a birthday uh that
my dad got me a small reef tank and it
just lit the fire underneath me and then
like my mom would drive me after school
so you're gonna like the las vegas zoo
one day i would love las vegas aquarium
i would love to but but but seriously
but but then i think that like that
that's luck i had no control over that
whatsoever uh but i i'm thinking too
like what would have happened had i been
born into another family where both
parents were uh like uh abusing drugs or
or
uh we're talking down to me all the time
or getting an argument
yeah
and like how would that mess with
my my confidence because i think too
it's like i've always been confident
that like if i do something i'm gonna be
good at it if i if as long as i give it
a hundred percent as long as i take it
serious it's gonna do well and i've
never had a doubt that i can't do
something but that was i think because
of my upbringing versus like imagine if
i did something like
i suck and just going into the live
thing and i'm or you had a little
success in your parents like
yeah yeah oh you're going a job
yeah one thing i'm very fortunate with
is my career in sports took me all
across the country so i've lived in like
10 different places i've lived in
georgia i lived in florida texas alabama
oakland california and so i've seen the
whole spectrum of people i've seen i've
been around wealth i've been around very
poor i've been on the bus with people
struggling from mental health i've seen
the whole spectrum of humanity and i
feel like that has played well into my
content where i i feel like i'm not
puff of myself i feel like i understand
humans pretty well yeah and the culture
and everything i want to actually talk
about that you just said your career in
sports but i do
briefly want to mention like it's like
for you graham i feel like if you
with the luck considered with everything
if you didn't have that luck i still
think that you would be like
disproportionately successful just based
off of your characteristic but i think
like what if you removed uh you know
like his his character like his ability
to be like relentlessly
into one thing or something like that if
you removed that would he still be
disproportionately successful i don't
think so that's a great he was if he was
as lucky but he didn't have that
character or here's another thing to
consider we see so many people that they
have like a string of luck and they they
you know they make all this money and
they have access to all of this like
this working capital they have access to
you know funds all of this stuff but
they don't capitalize off of it you know
like they have one string of luck and
then they're just content and they sit
there but graham also didn't do that
with real estate he was successful in
real estate but it didn't matter you
know like he utilized that to be
successful in youtube so i do think it
obviously it is a spectrum between the
two but for graham himself i think it
was more his actions definitely but to
get back to house hacking because that's
i know we want to talk about the uh the
strategy right now
is so valuable in las vegas i can't tell
you how many people need this
renting an affordable room in a safe
house nice house i furnish my rooms i
include utilities in the total cost so
my new house i get 9.50 for the master
750 for all the other rooms that share a
bathroom are you worried sharing rooms
with strangers in a story yeah i do my
buddy mate messaged me the other night
he rents by the room as well he's had a
really good string of good luck in in
that he is very good with uh finding the
right people
getting good people in his house
background checks credit checks you can
do the whole nine yards right he
messaged me the other night about
midnight bro 10 cops are at my house
whoa what's going on dude six are
undercover i don't know what's going on
hey man
are they there is this a sanity check is
this a mental health check on one of
your tenants like what's going on i
don't know man i go to sleep i wake up
like 10 messages bro you have no idea he
sent a las vegas review journal
of a
suspect for armed robberies
bro this is one of my roommates they got
him in custody what do i do
there's there's the downside of it now
granted this is all to be fair all real
estate you're gonna be dealing with
people people have problems and issues
every now and then at a certain unit
point even if you do the apartment
building thing you're gonna have people
that are
not great for whatever reason but yeah
he was freaking out what's crazy is i
actually went up and hung out with him
at that dude's house and when i didn't
have a car this guy actually gave me a
ride somewhere super nice guy actually
kind of looks similar to you like you
know nice-looking young guy he drove
uber he looks just like you jack
you know come to find out what have you
been doing on the weekends
but anyway so the downside is that i've
had a tenant pass away in my house i've
had i had a former ufc heavyweight yeah
i had a former ufc heavyweight fighter i
had him yell on my face one night that
was fun 6325 pretty big guy um so
there's there's there are downsides to
this isn't certainly not for everyone
but when you learn to manage it you can
you can
reduce the amount of headaches and
stress i gotta tell you i would never be
able to do that ever what's money is you
house hack right now don't you you got
roommates
whatever not yeah but like you have one
so you want to know funny logic
oh my god you have roommates wow why do
you have roommates you should live a
little you should live
in life you have the first 18 years
you're generally living with roommates
right family after that a lot of people
will go to college you're forced to live
with roommates you have an apartment you
live with roommates and friends and all
that and then there's a little a little
segment of life where you live alone you
can afford it you've got the job before
a lot of people get married or have a
serious relationship and then live with
someone for the rest of their life
theoretically you house hack basically
your whole life meaning you have
roommates what i do is i just get
roommates that pay me i haven't paid a
mortgage or rent since september august
of 2016. it's weird to me like thinking
about rent it's been so long like the
idea of paying to live somewhere i've
i've profited for the past five years
that's smart yeah that's what i wanted
to answer your question the one guy uh
the poor guy passed away in a mental
health or mental health excuse me a
health facility he he was not in the
house so he was a tenant he was a tenant
though
i had one guy by the way this is my
first property is in a nice area so for
some people looking to do this you can
look at numbers and you can uh you can
buy a property specifically for numbers
which is what i did would not recommend
it thankfully i'm at an income point now
where i can afford to live in nicer
you get a nicer tenant class a little
bit better on the
on the quality of tenant scale right
sure um a little bit better jobs better
employment but you never know man things
can happen i've never had fights that's
something i never had to deal with are
you
are you concerned about uh because right
now i think it's a numbers game yeah and
you get enough tenants enough buildings
eventually you're gonna get disputes
where like 110 it doesn't like another
tenant or i
hey i've dealt with it all i've got a
camera in one of my houses i've got
people all right so i was eating eating
my food out of the fridge i was hanging
out with my buddy taylor the other day
he rents by the room he does the extreme
he has like eight people in a house and
one guy's like hey man joe just punched
me
kicked him out of the house he's like
really when did it happen we look on his
phone on his security camera and it's
like the action happens you can see it
you can see it on the camera and then 30
minutes like hey man we're cool we we
brushed it off don't worry about it i'm
gonna have to see that footage yeah so
this this stuff happens wow it's funny
so this but but my comeback to all this
is what's an easy way to make money have
you figured it out have you ever figured
out an easy way to make money i'm
talking an easy way to make to make good
money yeah an easy way like there's no
easy way like you're either gonna have
to hustle on youtube for years or you're
gonna have to work work a job like at
some point you're gonna have to put in
work to make money and the downsides of
this is every now and then you're gonna
have
some type of dispute some type of spat
uh someone went into someone's room i
had one so and so stole my watch i'm
like i mean how do you how do you manage
that yeah here's the thing though i
think your time is starting to be more
valuable agreed better spent elsewhere
so like how long do you think you'll
continue doing this for until you
realize it's like
even if one thing stresses you out a day
just one little thing is that worth
potentially sacrificing that thought
process or that that mental capacity for
the rest of the day it's a great
conversation number one my new house i
don't even like remember i own it
because my roommates don't even text me
or anything they're so easygoing so i do
think when you swing into the kind of
the upper scale of housing better tenant
class it's easier i'm telling you the
extreme stories i've been doing this for
a long time
most of the time probably 99.99
is nothing you just wake up and go to
sleep like a normal day i'd shoot my
youtube videos nothing happens but every
now and then something happens and i
actually gave jack here a checklist
there's a lot of problems that i've been
dealt with and you can solve them
beforehand i want to see the rules so
you came in and you said you want to see
him right here yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
you said you had house rules i give it
to everyone so these are are these
strict house rules or are they i make it
very clear that when you move in you
will follow these rules all right yeah
and these are all all these rules you
wrote them down because of some event
that occurred pretty much most of them
yeah so they usually have a story
most of them do go by number one uh
number one here if you like to play
music noise levels must be at a
reasonable level
i've found i found yeah most of these
are fair by the way they're not like too
sexy but what i found is
quiet is best for everyone some everyone
lives differently some people totally
cool with noise others like myself has
to be silent here we go i like this a
reasonable level is defined as barely
being audible outside of your room with
the door closed fair in the event that
one roommate needs the noise to be
turned off other roommates must comply
with their wishes that's fair i like it
very much don't you think that could be
a beaut let's say the two roommates
getting a spat i was like well you know
what i want your music off i'm the
dictator
my rules go
so you should uh deal with this by the
way
there's not many noise i make it very
clear when people so here's the thing
for you if you want to do this um you'll
see on uh on the checklist at the end
you set a culture within a house hack
this is very important it's kind of like
a company so before people move in i
make it very clear i say it's not going
to hurt my feelings if you don't want to
move in but if you move in
i'm making it very clear here's the
rules that you follow number one it is
quiet at all times this is inexcusable
quiet at all times you will be clean i
hire a maid service but these are the uh
rules that you will follow no matter
what and it's very clear and when they
move in the culture is already
established that's so smart yeah so you
um my buddy taylor i told you about the
punch yeah he said what he didn't do
well with that property is it was kind
of a party house he was living in at the
time and the the people that move in
kind of join the culture right if it's a
party house and you're here we got every
friday night we got dinner and drinks
and all this stuff going on well when
people move in they're going to be a
part of that and they're going to join
or if you want it students only super
quiet everyone works from home super
quiet when the next person moves in
they'll abide by the rules what i found
the rental demand right now is so high i
could buy two more properties tomorrow
and have them booked with great tenants
it is so high right now because i
furnish and i include utilities and i
never raise rent so when you move in
it's super easy for a lot of people
there's a transient town so this might
only really work in vegas this model
what i'm doing because i've got a lot of
people moving to town they need a
furnished place
all in 750 a month
really nice three-story 500 000 house
and kind of an upper scale neighborhood
you can't beat that you know you know
where i think you would make a lot of
money more than youtube is uh
replicating that business model and just
starting your own management company
i've talked about that with my buddy
macha and taylor who do this and if we
get to a certain point we'll hire
full-time and then that's where the
criticism of when when will this be too
much will hopefully be solved by that
full-time i'm telling you man if you
just take 10 or 12 15 and you say we
will take your five bedroom house you
want the numbers by the way on my new
house i know you like numbers yeah sure
just so you can uh get an idea
i just maybe you want to i do want to
say like with the clips exclusive maybe
we shouldn't use this as a clip suit if
it's really good content because
the most important thing is the podcast
we'll just see how this is fair enough
yeah we'll go through this
yeah you are not allowed to enter
another roommate's room without prior
consent one issue i have never dealt
with i punching people and going into
people's rooms there's some like respect
that people have
i've never seen someone go into another
person's room yeah i wouldn't uh unless
it's to take jack's rolex
you're waking up a little later on
saturday cool all right quiet time is
between 10 p.m and 8 a.m do people
people run the blender at midnight and
you're like come on guys what are you
doing it seems like elementary school it
does this is baby scenario this is
baby's life
yeah this is babysitting i i have had
kids before this is these are all
teenagers i have a problem with this one
okay okay i'm be real laundry is not
allowed after 11 p.m i'll peak
electrical hours man please plan
accordingly here's why so i have a
converted garage in my uh current house
hack and so the laundry's right there
and it's super loud i couldn't sleep run
the garbage disposal in anything but
water is sent down the drain that's good
i've seen someone put down oil and
grease and i'm sitting there like oh my
god i just dealt with a thirty thousand
dollar sewage problem please not put
grease down there yeah wow yeah no oil
grease to be sent down the drain
wow please
yeah
wow yeah the cost of paper towel is
significantly less than the cost of
replacing the draining system yeah
you'll like that yeah okay i like that
uh please do your best to take out the
trash whenever the trash has reached the
ceiling of the trash can i put a
recycling bin next to the trash can for
the recycling jack we should we should
get in the habit of that man
jack and alex looking through i take out
the trash all the time i take out the
trash do you have someone here that that
keeps filling it up over and never takes
it out all of us do i don't even use
your trash can well yeah you do
all right please do not leave anything
in the kitchen sink jack
i provide as many materials to dry
utensils a quick soap and rinse is clean
enough okay i like that if you have
anything in the kitchen that uh you
would like no one else to use please
notify every roommate that said item is
off limits i had some i had someone with
like a very special coffee yeah coffee
mug what do you call mug and it was uh
it was special to him and so just make
it clear that's good i like this did
that uh did that special mug happen to
be
one of the limited edition sign mugs now
for sale at pinkgirlcoffee.com
am i supposed to answer yeah yeah what
do i you want me to plug it no no no no
no
three years ago now this was three years
ago but if it happened today i know
where to buy it please be mindful of the
noise levels if you happen to bring over
guests at night jack the noise rules
still apply when guests are over jack
with the with the house with thin walls
you know you got a relationship you know
there's some noises tonight i heard some
wild noises coming the other night jack
that a boy from where from your room
from my room when i went in this was
last week i went into the office
and it was like a grunting sound
don't spread this that is not true i'm
not even allowed to have friends i'm
kidding i'm not allowed to have people
over i had to get you i'm kidding that's
a show that's the last rule you get to
read
graham graham's only rule is no randoms
so you want a story i had i had one guy
who was up in the master and he he had a
buddy coming in he had like a cousin
come in for a while for a day or two no
problem right stay for a day after three
or four days like hey how long does he
stand oh his flight something something
he's going to stand another couple days
well then there was an issue with the
mma fighter the heavyweight in the
garage i'm sitting at work i'm working
at like a nice tech company software
development right and i'm getting texts
from this guy and that guy yo this
so-and-so the heavyweight's coming up to
my room and trying to fight my brother
and the brother's saying he's like this
is my house and he doesn't live here in
in the heavyweight is obviously a very
confrontational guy so he's up there
banging on the door and he's like come
on out and i'm sitting at my job and i'm
freaking out like what what's going on
you know hopefully not a fight yeah
ended up subsiding but they they got
into a disagreement so that was the
thing with the guests wow yeah
uh keep windows and doors closed at all
times during the summer and winter
months as the electric bill will be
significantly higher if we are blowing
air to the outside yeah my buddy mate
the one who dealt with the uh the armed
robbery guy just recently he had some
girl that just moved out and another
tenant said that she had left her window
open all summer an electric bill was
twice what it was last year
yeah these are all good rules please do
not eat others food unless given consent
in the f in the event that food was
mistakenly eaten please offer to
reimburse the roommate for the food oh i
would ram i would up charge that so high
so much what
okay the only time i ate jack's food the
only time
uh jack had watermelon in the fridge but
he had a lot of watermelon and it was
looking so good you can justify it
however you want yeah there was plenty
of jack there was i offered to i offered
to reimburse you
which i thought was so ridiculous but
thank you i appreciate that no i i you
didn't need to reimburse me that was the
point cause jack eats so much of my food
all the bars macy buys she goes to the
grocery store i don't eat the bars
who eats the bars
which bars
no cigarettes or
smoking it we'll bleep that out inside
any
or no cigarettes smoking inside smoking
state
you just said it no cigarettes or
smoking okay no cigarettes or smoking of
any substance green stuff smoking inside
under any circumstance i do not want to
see any cigarette butts in the yard if
you smoke discard the cigarette in the
trash properly gram
cigarettes make a yard so trashy man
yeah because cigarette smokers just
haven't
they just seem to always flick them on
the ground i i did actually see someone
throw a cigarette outside of their car
yesterday oh it happens all the time the
freeway and you see like the little
orange yeah
yeah i hate that please do not leave the
house when your clothes are being washed
in the washer out of respect for others
who may need to do the law who may need
to do the laundry if you're talking
about energy yeah that does make hey so
and so so and so is laundry can you tell
them to get it it's like come on
man if you need to leave the house in
your clothes or in the dryer please
provide a laundry basket for others to
place your clothes in so you can
continue i include that in your
checklist by the way you might want to
go get like a small hamper to put by the
laundry dude
man basically every every i've dealt
with like every problem and the way i
operate is you bring me a problem i find
a solution to implement so that it'll
never happen you could sell these
spreadsheets like these these rules i
mean that's great
uh take out dryland after use this is
mandatory we are risking the house being
burnt down if the dryer lint is not
adequately removed you'd be shocked how
many people don't remove
yeah dryer lint i don't uh nothing
foreign goes down the toilet this
includes but is not limited to
uh condoms graham uh blunts
and food jack
if you order food please be alert for
the food when the delivery has arrived
that's fair
lock the door lock the back door
whenever you return inside this is
mandatory to ensure safety for all
roommates yeah that's smart if there is
an urgent need for anything that i have
not provided please text me asap and i
will reimburse you for the expense
that's good i always try to be a great
landlord i think i'm the best landlord
in vegas like my the goal with house
hacking is to always provide the best
experience to your tenants and i try to
implement that every day yeah if you're
having any issue related to the house or
between another roommate and don't feel
like you can settle it yourself please
let me know by text asap which i think
is great asap to squash the beef
immediately once it occurs so there's no
do something like please uh settle it
yourselves please settle
with your food what's the coin toss it's
bad it's just you can't just like an arm
wrestled what i'm excited about with
this next house is i'm gonna now uh be
able to manage the first house hack from
afar which is something i haven't had to
deal with yet that'll be interesting too
because if it works i'm going to scale
this pretty quickly
um
if you damage anything on the property
is your responsibility to reimburse me
for fixing the damage
there let's see your numbers yeah yeah
let's see it so you usually add a unit
though so you buy a house and then you
somehow like add a wall or something
like that that's the goal i look to
maximize the properties as best i can so
my new one i have it's a 5'4 and i'll
show you pictures but i'm converting a
downstairs living room into a sixth
bedroom it's free cash flow whenever you
have the ability to do this you
generally have lofts upstairs can be
converted you have potential dining
rooms and then in my case on a
three-story house downstairs living room
i'll give you the numbers for the new
house so purchase price of hundred
twenty five thousand dollars down which
was five percent it appraised for 4.95
so i needed to come out 5 000
unfortunately 7 500 closing costs all in
about 37.5
4 000 all in if you include buying
furniture and other various things so
i'm about 3 100 a month gross
expenses 3 100 a month and i'm getting
39.50 income
so while living in the property i'll be
cash flowing 850 a month got it my other
house the 7 bed it grosses
4 600
40 whatever it's like 46.50 or whatever
it comes out to and the total expenses
with maid servicing all utilities and
everything is about 2100. let's call it
another 200 a month for various so 2300
it'll it'll gross somewhere around our
net 2 300 a month cash flow so i'll be
about 3 000 a month net cash flow
between the two
so what's the
what's it look like in today's market so
you're buying something let's just say
we'll call it 550 because the market's
going up putting let's just let's just
call it fifteen percent down so you're
putting eighty two five plus another
let's just say fifteen thousand
different expenses closing out let's say
100k yep
hundred thousand five bedrooms what
would
you what would you get per month on that
well between five i'd get i get 39.50
for mine so if you buy in kind of that i
think there's a sweet spot right now
right in the in the 550 range it's the
perfect model for house hacking so you'd
be somewhere around 39.50 you could
probably get a little more if you pushed
it but i i prefer coming in a little
below market i think people stay longer
and they enjoy it more if they feel like
they're getting a deal
so i'm just doing some numbers here so
i'll walk you through it so uh
we're looking about
yeah i see okay so it's gonna be about
three thousand thirty one hundred
dollars a month correct okay that by the
way that includes high speed internet
all utilities and made service and i did
no pmi for mine
i did a lender paid up front so let's
just say worst case thirty three hundred
yeah
so you're making six hundred and fifty
dollars a month correct which is seventy
eight hundred dollars a year so seven
point eight percent return and it'll be
about 750 a month for the pay down
principal paydown right right so you add
another nine grand a year for principal
paydown
and you also live for free so there's
the opportunity cost right so most
people live for probably eight hundred
dollars a month if you include all these
i'm saying for an investor
like if i were looking to do it well it
would be even higher than it would yeah
because you would put more down more so
it would be basically this the same
thing if you so i'm calculating this the
same if you took a managed management
fee let's say 12 15 or whatever it is
you'd be looking at a total return of
16.8 a year on a hundred thousand with
equity pay down or cash flow you'd be
looking at like eight percent with a
management fee yeah
i think those numbers are a little high
by the way if you put down 20 you should
be in the 2300 ballpark
i think there's another 300 or so a
month
that you would you're you're adding in
oh yeah yeah you're right you're an
investor yeah you're right you're right
right uh yeah i put loan amount 550
instead of the purchase price so yeah so
1971 so you're right so yeah so uh so 78
and keep in mind what i do is with the
six bed i i get i'm gonna get six beds
for mine i'll be at 4 700 a month in
income when i move out of my my new
house right so so take the expenses was
let's call it 3 000 for everything right
so you'll be at 1700 a month cash flow
for one property yeah right so yeah so
this this comes at 775 a month with a
management fee
if you were to do that with this you
can't match the returns and as far as
house hacking you cannot match the
returns it's the best way to get started
in real estate i run a meet up here in
town and a lot of beginners come and
they just seem so lost because it's so
hard to get started now because the
buried entry is so high man like if you
have if you make 50 000 a year how are
you going to get into real estate if you
have 10 000 saved out good credit score
and everything lines up how do you get
started how do you go get a hard money
loan if they want 20
total costs right how do you get a hard
money loan okay that's hard wholesaling
incredibly competitive and requires
marketing fees going to get your license
you could do that that's a good start
but to me house hacking is for most
people and
because a lot of the a lot of the
comeback is oh well i have a girlfriend
or i have a spouse or whatever you can
house hack you could get a casita in my
current house you could wall off the
downstairs which will cost about two
thousand dollars so it's a tri-level
right you can go upstairs down if you go
downstairs and wall it off you could
have its own unit downstairs basically
be an unpermitted duplex downstairs
would have two beds one bath and you
could even kind of form a kitchenette
so that would combat any type of issues
about living with others is you would
essentially have your own unit
if that makes sense right so you read
the four rooms upstairs you break even
yeah
in la that's never something you would
do because all it takes is one neighbor
to complain about an unpermitted edition
or a wall or anything like that you're a
man of uh following the rules yeah yeah
because well here's the thing if there's
a fire it's it's always for fire
compliance like that's the right
what are the exit points what about the
person on the second unit how many exit
points do they have where the windows
um
yeah what was it i got cited too for
something i put the
i forget what it was i had the wrong and
i bought a property but it had the wrong
type of uh i took the bars off no it
didn't the bar's off the window yeah
yeah yeah the playstation you see that
in l.a i've been picturing like a
million dollar property with bars oh no
no no it was weird to me not to have
bars in the window seriously oh that's
not good yeah it was always yeah because
growing up uh we had bars i never knew
it was not a thi not a thing to have
bars in the window yeah
you know what it was uh actually when
when macy uh uh first came over i think
she mentioned the bars on the window and
and her thinking was that this is not
it's not like a safe area because it had
they all every house itself that's why
you have them here it's like brings back
memories of home right
no but but so anyway so like for me it
was like growing up we had bars in the
way but like everybody what are the bars
for uh to prevent people from getting in
the house so it is for safety yeah yeah
but uh yeah so anyway for the compliance
it was uh
the bar uh the the the bars on the
bedrooms
had to be one where if you pushed it
from the inside they would swing open in
case of a fire so that you're not
trapped
the metal
bars and one of the master bedrooms when
i bought the place did not do that or it
was like it was only like partially
opened i don't know so i had to fix that
i do have a question for you since that
thread's over what's your relationship
with the algorithm with the analytic
with your youtube analytics and i leave
that question open or like that i'll
leave that question over here
yeah cause i'll answer after you yeah
your answer you're real close extremely
close because i
i am in a way like not in a good
relationship with it because our careers
on youtube are so tied to the numbers
and analytics that it can almost become
unhealthy where you're sitting there
checking the numbers and it becomes all
about numbers and oh today it's 50 i've
looked at some of your numbers on the
social blade right some months it's like
50 less i know you feel that yeah but if
you look at macro level i'm doing pretty
well in life and you're doing pretty
darn well yourself
should we really care about that much
and i know i know for you yeah you take
the youtube series but anyway at what
point i'm just curious at what point do
you start making enough money where you
just go i'm putting them well
if you don't care it's a hobby if you
have no problem just going and posting
what you want do it it's a hobby i love
the aspect of a business to me i take it
so seriously and it's like an income has
not changed at all this has been the
same behavior for a couple years oh my
gosh that's that's the only way to get
to past a million subscribers is to be
relentless with the algae you have to
treat it like a business and you have to
be meticulous if a video doesn't do well
you have to find the solution just like
you're about finding solutions you got
to find a solution to why a video is not
performing where did you go wrong and
sometimes it's like we pick a topic
that's too niche that's my bad oh well i
won't do that again
or you post a video that should have
done really well but then it's like well
what's wrong with the title what's wrong
with the thumbnail how could i how can i
fix this
it's that's never going to disappear i
was just curious if you have and maybe
you aren't able to sense it in yourself
but if if anyone not just saying you if
you get to a point where you're making a
lot of money and you're still like so
tied to that at what point you detach
you have to then you stop caring then
you stop going then it's like you may as
well at that point be like all right
well then i'm retiring or or i'm just
not gonna care but then you let the
business die that's what you're doing
it's like you built up a successful
company you're like oh now i'm just not
going to care about it anymore you have
to be so on point with all of it um now
now here's you're talking about views
decline now here's where it gets me
if if if mine is an isolated incident if
my channel is going down well at the
same time everyone else is going up then
i know it's an issue with me and that's
something i can control and then that's
something where i gotta pinpoint where
i'm going wrong
if i see it where every single finance
channel is down 50
from where they were in the beginning of
the year and it's across the board i'm
not doing anything wrong that is just
the general momentum of the market and
at the end of the day worth of whims of
just what people want to hear about what
they're clicking on uh because i know
your summers are you're still in the
strategy of when i can tell when a video
is not performing i know your numbers
when the video's not performing that
title and thumbnail gets changed
and i would never speak on other
people's health like mental health and
your like relationship with the
analytics but i wonder at what point do
you have a good enough life where you
can detach and it doesn't sound like
it's affecting you negatively i know i
love it yeah okay good i think my sense
and tell me if i'm wrong my sense is
you've had enough success for like the
money problem solved you're good in life
you're comfortable you've got good
people around you so this becomes your
focus it's like a game team i've always
regardless of money how much are you
making it's like it's a game so if you
can beat the game that's your choice
yeah correct the money's never been
never been a goal believe it or not i
know it's uh it's it's odd because from
the outside it's easy to judge oh 100
but i've i've been just the same as i am
today as it was when i was making no
money on youtube like absolutely nothing
and i was still taking it just as
seriously i love it and same thing with
working as a real estate agent it was
the money was great i love it but it was
never like i was never like i gotta sell
this house so i make the money i just i
had so much fun with it and just and and
i think the the accumulation of of of
building wealth and investing it that's
a byproduct of just
i i love it so much that uh like and and
there is an element where it's like i do
feel sometimes it's like well if this
video like yesterday's video was was
something where it's like it it was
frustrating than anything because i i'm
so happy about this video but i think
just
we were using titles that uh people uh
have gotten used to we gotta find so
this is the thing like like uh the
program it's like now we gotta find a
new angle right because the current
titles the stock market just blanked
that format worked three months ago
it doesn't work anymore yeah every
single video the stock market just
flipped flopped top one topped peaked
whatever just you could pick any and
we'll look through the dictionary
literally we'll pick words that that we
think are cool and really uh what was
there's a few of them in there um that
are just random words they don't mean
anything there'll be a word that works
like the stock market just and then a
word and then if it performs
successfully you know you can't just use
that same word but we use that same
format the stock market just and then we
just type in that word synonym and then
just like go through like an entire list
of words like what what seems like it
will work whatever you've truly treated
it like like a like an algorithm yeah
and then you could uh
yeah and then you could apply that to
well if the stock market just flipped
what about real estate the real estate
market i'm just fascinated for from a
guy like you've had so much financial
success you know what at what point
because
we're all different too but okay here
this is it the stock market is about to
snap
that was a word that was like it just
hit it it sounds good it doesn't mean it
the snap was snapped totally just
but it's a good title like i liked that
title thank you so much for coming on
spencer it was nice officially meeting
you today thank you for all of your
guidance i've been dming you for like i
don't even know how many months now
couple weeks yeah a couple months it's
probably a couple months it's been over
a month talking about real estate in las
vegas and how to house hack and stuff
like that so thank you all so much for
that for that advice and uh thank you
for showing up here the best place to
start if you want to get started in real
estate house hacking baby look at the
camera that one right there and tell
them to destroy the like button
you need to destroy that like button
right now and subscribe
you need to destroy that like button
right now and subscribe
cool so thank you guys so much for
watching thank you so much for coming on
also make sure to get your free stock
down below in the description just use
the code gram it's worth all the way up
to a thousand dollars in public thousand
dollars a thousand dollars that could
start you on your house hacking yeah
right there yeah if you get the thousand
dollar one that that that's great you
have to manage tenants for a thousand
bucks and you're telling me you can just
send it to get a free
enjoy that free stock guys thank you so
much for coming on i really appreciate
it thanks for having me until next time
that once more i'd say your last name
too
last name oh yeah